- Welcome, everyone.
I'm Ming Wu, I'm the Head of Engineering
for Rovo Dev from Atlassian.
Super excited to be here with you all.
Today, I'm going to share
some interesting findings
from Atlassian's recent
State of Developer Experience Report 2025.
So, you may think measuring
developer experience,
it's pretty common, we
have done that, right?
There's a lot of established
metrics in the industry
and your companies, I'm sure,
every company has built certain dashboard
to bring the visibility to those metrics.
And most of those metrics are measuring
developer productivity as approximation
to developer experience.
But are we actually
measuring the right thing?
What if we are measuring the wrong thing?
The reason we say that is,
we all have seen the cases
where all the metrics are
pointing to a very rosy picture.
However, we know our teams are suffering,
they're burning out.
So, if this is not the
right way to measure,
then what would be the
right way to measure?
The intuitive thinking is to
ask your developers, right?
They will tell you.
So, at the beginning
of the survey we did start
asking the developers,
how do you actually feel
to be a developer today?
Not how fast, not how productive they are,
but how do they feel to
be a developer today?
So, the reason being, you know,
last past 12 months, so
many things have changed.
We've had rapid development for AI,
platform engineering has taken off.
All these changes,
we really wanna understand
how developers are
taking in those changes.
How does those changes actually
change their day to day?
And also how do the developers
and their leaders think
about the productivity?
So, we started asking the simple question,
how do you feel like to
be a developer today?
Just a second.
Obviously, we're dealing
with a developer crowd.
So, when you ask a simple question,
you may get all kinds
of different answers.
So, I'll show you some examples.
How does it feel to be a developer today?
We got this.
"I feel hungry, they cancelled
Friday night pizzas."
Well, not exactly what
we were looking for,
but good to know.
Second one is my favorite.
"I don't know, ask ChatGPT."
Clearly AI has a lot of impact
on our developers today.
"It depends, what do
you mean by developer?"
This is valid, philosophical.
You know, with AI tools,
everyone now can develop code.
What do you mean really by developer?
So clearly, with this question
we're not getting what we want.
We thought about this
and for the second annual
State of the Dev Experience survey,
we sent out the survey to
focus on three questions.
One, how has developer experience evolved
over the past 12 months?
Second one, what's the impact
of AI on developer daily life?
Third one, how does developers
and their leaders think
about productivity?
So, we use three questions to anchor
the developer experience to
get a well-rounded answer.
We actually sent out the
survey to 3,500 developers
and their leaders globally.
So, we have some really
good insights from here.
At the end of the presentation,
I included a QR code.
You can scan and download the full report
if you wanna know more details.
But in this rest of the session,
we're gonna touch on some
highlighted findings.
So, before we jump into the report,
maybe one thing I really want to touch on
is why developer
experience is so important.
Let's be honest, all
the software companies,
they have one common goal.
They wanna deliver
high-quality software, fast.
Simple, simple as that.
But let's break it down a bit.
What do you mean by quality?
Quality can mean different things.
Usually it means your
software has to be resilient,
compliant and maybe performant.
But if we look at the
different angle on this one,
which this angle is not usually mentioned,
but this is what really we want it for,
the quality means you
deliver the right value
to your customer, you deliver
what your customer want to the customer.
So, that is the quality.
Second one, let's look
at what's fast, right?
Fast, it doesn't necessarily
mean you have 10 production
drops per day.
That's not fast.
Fast really means you can actually deliver
at the right speed without the constraint
of industry processes and frameworks.
Being able to deliver fast
give you competitive advantage.
It means you can deliver
the customer values
at the right speed.
You are ahead of the competition.
It means you can comply with
your regulators ahead of time.
So, they wanna deliver the value fast
and it's a simple statement.
Easier said than done.
So, let's come back now to the question,
why developer experience is important?
It's because developer
experience is a key ingredient
to developer productivity.
Developer experience is about
removing the friction points
developer face when they use
tools, frameworks and processes
and removing friction
points for developers
leading to a happier developer
who will deliver
high-quality software faster.
So, that's why it's important.
Remember that point
'cause removing the friction points
is one thing we found really insightful.
That's how we think there's
huge opportunities in terms
of leveraging the AI tools
for improving developer experience.
Okay, so now let's look at the numbers.
So, let's look at the AI and
the developer experience.
First, we all know
most developers probably
already adopted the AI tools.
You know?
Over past 12 months,
a lot of things have changed.
Vibe coding 12 months ago,
probably means you put
down your favorite song
and doing the writing code
and now it means a
completely different thing.
So, we observed most of the developers
have adopted coding assistance.
Stack Overflow survey
from 2024 has shown 82%
of the developers are
already using Generative AI
for writing code.
It's not surprising.
They get a lot from the coding assistant.
In fact, coding assistant is
probably one of the fastest
adopted tools developer
technology of all time.
Really not surprising.
But remember what we said,
developer experience is about
removing friction points.
Coding is not really a point of friction.
If you ask any developers
do they want a really fully
automate coding, they don't
have to do code anymore?
I doubt anyone will say yes.
So, coding assistant can
enhance developer experience
but without actually improving it.
This is a bit counterintuitive,
but if you think about it,
our survey shows developers only spend 16%
of the time on coding.
It is not surprising, right?
If you're a developer,
you know most of the time
during the SDLC you have
to start from ideation,
writing specs, writing docs,
aligning with everyone,
talking to PMs and do planning.
And then you get to coding.
But once you get to coding,
the most interesting part,
you have to do testing,
you have to do the review,
then you have to do deployment
and you have to monitor
and repeat this process.
So, only 16% of the time they
really spend on the coding.
So.
(people chattering)
So, if you look at the entire
software development life cycle,
84% time were spent outside of coding.
This is a huge opportunity
here for AI tools to help.
So, with our survey, we
really wanna understand
how developers are using AI
to actually remove the friction points
to address the pain points
in their development life.
Then we got a list.
So, we started from the bottom.
Outside of coding, developers
are using the AI tools
for automating some of the boring tasks.
And this is not surprising, you know,
even before AI tools,
developers are trying
to automate everything by writing scripts.
So, automation is
definitely a first thing,
they use the AI tools to help.
So, we look at the...
Atlassian has 60K developers.
So, we look at some internal
examples, how we use AI tools
to automate our life.
And this is a good example.
This is how we actually
use AI tools to deal
with the removal of the feature flags.
Feature flags are probably
one of the common tech
that every company has.
You know, they were used
to release certain feature,
they got left behind
because in case something happened
and then nobody goes back to clean them.
So, they start stacking
on top of each other
and become tech debt.
And this is the single boring task
that nobody really wanna do.
So, in Atlassian we create a Rovo agent
to handle removing the
clean up the feature flags
and then we leverage the
automation platform in Atlassian
and really automating
the feature flag clean up
as a workflow.
So, this really helps the developers
to remove the kind of tasks,
repetitive tasks they really do not like.
But more importantly,
this is only not just
handling the boring tasks,
it is actually freeing the developers
to focus on more valuable
and more innovative tasks
that they really like.
Oops.
(people chattering)
So, number three on the
list is documentation.
Not surprising.
AI has already done a really
great job on documentation.
So, the third case we found on the list
is folks are using the the
AI tools for documentation.
One example
from Atlassian is the pipelines
deployment summarizer.
You know, who here really
wanna write the release note?
Nobody really, right?
This is some tasks that nobody
wish they would need to do.
So, in Atlassian we have a pipeline agent
that summarizes the
deployment once a deployment
is going out.
So, this is not only automate the task,
it also help enforcing the standard.
It helps standardize the process
so that we won't miss
in case manually down
and someone will miss this step,
you have to push them to do.
But this really helps not
only handling the pain points
but also pushing for the standardization.
(people chattering and laughing)
Number two on the list is testing.
Not surprising.
Developers and testings
love-hate relationship
all the time.
We all know testing is important,
but you know, it's kind of
repetitive sometimes to write,
test and improve the test coverage.
So...
(audience clapping)
What we do in Atlassian,
we developed a test-writing agent
and it helps to write the unit test
and improve your repo unit test coverage.
And combining with the automation
is a very powerful tool.
It goes detect to your test coverage
and automatically generate unit test.
Okay, now let's be honest,
this process has to have human review
because some of the tests are easier,
some of the tests are harder.
So,
developers have to look
at the PR sometimes
to decide whether this test is correct
and we have to actually
run to make sure it builds.
However, you know, with
this automated process
for test generation, at
least it's a good start.
It does the heavy lifting.
Now you can focus on maybe
make the minor changes
and it helps a lot to speed up,
increasing the unit test coverage.
(person coughing)
(people chattering)
Okay, so now, we're onto the first one.
So first one, searching for information.
This shouldn't be any surprise to anyone.
Knowledge discovery is super important,
especially as your project running longer,
more people are involved in the process
and more contexts are generated.
Your code base get bigger,
it will become harder
and harder to search for
the information you want.
And on average, I believe,
everyone's probably spent
a couple of hours a week
at least to search for the
right information you want,
gather the context for your project
before you even write the code.
So, this is really an example to...
Developers are using AI to really help.
So Atlassian, how we do it,
we do have a Rovo searching
house and this is GA product.
So, if you're using Atlassian product,
you should have seen this as well.
Rovo Search helps you
to effectively retrieve
the relevant information from
your document content base.
It's not just for Jira
and Confluence, it
provides a 3P connector.
So, you can actually search
through 3P content like SharePoint.
(people chattering)
Okay, so, now we're seeing,
it's fantastic to see developers
already using AI tools
to address the pain point outside coding.
You know, there are a bunch
of tasks they have find value
and now we wanna know with all this,
how much time really
does it save them, right?
It's nice to use those tools,
but does it really help?
Okay, so 38% of the developers experience
the productivity gains
in last year's report.
If you take a guess this year,
what would be the number?
(people chattering)
In 2025,
99% of developers claim they are saving
at least four hours per week
using the AI tools.
You know, this number
when it just came out,
it's a bit controversial.
A lot of people are
skeptical about this number.
Really? Does 99% of people
already see the gains?
Because we know like a lot of people
are using coding assistant,
but not 99%, right?
So, 99% people actually claim
AI helped them saving time.
So, let's look at this.
Let's dig into the 99% a bit.
Actually 46% of people
claim it's saving them 11
to 20 hours per week.
But this is really raising eyebrows.
Is it really that much?
So, when we actually look at the data,
you know, we found out
if you're actually using
AI tools to address
a lot of friction point
along the software development lifecycle,
you will see actually
efficiency got improved.
You know, like we just said,
developers are using AI
to search for content,
knowledge and discovery.
They use it for automating
to help generate test,
improve the test coverage.
They use it for documentation
and they use it automate their tasks.
You know, all those together,
they're claiming every week,
you know, close to 50% of
developers are saving 11
to 20 hours a week.
This is huge.
This is also really promising
data points to show us that,
you know, if you think
about along the entire
software development lifecycle,
there's a huge opportunity there
for us to improve
efficiency, really use AI
to improve developer experience.
So now, you know, we look at this number,
you should ask your question,
especially the leaders should
ask the question, okay,
now we're saving time,
but what are developers
using this time for?
Are they using the time to watch YouTube
or are they playing game with this time?
This is a valid question.
So, (titters) we also ask the developers,
they are putting the
time to the good uses.
So, they are using the extra
time to improve code quality.
They're using that to
developing new features,
pleasing the PMs and they're
using it to improve culture.
That's great, you know,
good for team bonding
and they also use it for
generating more documentation.
It is great, you know,
it's fantastic to see
and we have the robots are doing things
and
it is a very good future
when we look at that.
And it's, more importantly, you know,
developers are using the time responsibly.
It's not like they're using the time
just for doing something else.
So you know, we can save time,
but productivity may not improve.
Okay, so now, next question is,
we now proved developers
are using AI to save time,
but are they more productive?
It seems like a counterintuitive
question, right?
They're just using the...
They already use the AI tools to improve
their productivity and to save time.
But are they really more productive?
To get some insight we
actually asked them,
each week, how much time
do they actually waste in inefficiency?
The answer is pretty shocking.
In 2025, 50% of the developers
claim they lost 10 hours of
their week due to inefficiency.
And 90% of developers saying
they're losing six plus hours
of the week due to inefficiency.
This is big, this is huge.
We have a huge gap here.
It's almost like one full day
of the week they're
wasted in inefficiency.
So, okay, so I'm not gonna say
too much about the picture,
but you know,
it's an analogy,
you save time on one side
but you losing time on the other.
And why is that?
You know, when you think about this,
why there is this disconnection?
We're using AI tools,
but on the other side,
inefficiency actually increased.
So, our theory hasn't
changed from the beginning.
Ours, remember when we were,
earlier, we were talking about
developer experience is about
removing friction points.
We have to understand the
friction points in order
to removing them properly.
So, without a good understanding
of the friction points,
we won't be able to address
the right pain points
or we won't be able to address
them in the proper way.
How do we address them?
We follow the same methodology
for any experimentation.
First, we have to understand
the friction points.
We send a survey, we talk to developers,
we gather their opinions,
then we identify.
Second, we need to create the measures,
putting the right measure in place.
Then you can find out, you know,
whether you can actually improve or not.
Then you take into the action,
really do the improvement.
Next, you gather the feedback again
and ask the developers and really measure
and looking at the metrics,
then iterate the whole process.
So, it's the same as any
scientific experiment process.
You from discover the
problem, you build the metrics
and you execute and then you go back,
iterate the whole process.
So.
So, now, we are starting
from the first point, right?
The whole process start
from the first point,
understanding the friction.
Then we actually thought,
we're asking the developers,
do they think their leaders
actually understand the friction point?
Surprisingly or maybe not surprisingly,
63% of developers saying their leaders
don't understand their challenges.
There's a big disconnection here.
If we don't understand
the friction points,
how do we know what to address?
How do we make sure we are addressing
the right friction points?
Leaders really need to understand
and talk to developers to
understand their challenge
and really the friction points
and developers should also raise
their concerns to the leaders.
So, I'll give you an example
for why this framework works
and we have validated with
an example internally.
So, in Atlassian with 60,000, oh sorry,
with 6,000 developers,
the code review cycle
is really a big problem.
You know, we noticed people are
complaining about, you know,
review cycle is too long
and it's blocking the deployment on that.
So, one way to push for
that would be ask everyone,
ask the developers, you
should do code reviews faster.
You should pick up the code
reviews as long as it comes up.
You know, however, when
we analyzed the problem,
it's actually not really about
they're slow on picking
up the code reviewers,
it's really about the
developers have to spend time
to understand the PR,
understand the code base
to point out some of the basic errors
and the basic round of
the review comments.
So, our approach here, we used
the Rovo Dev Code Reviewer,
we enabled that for entire Atlassian.
So, every PR, when it's submitted,
the code reviewer will be triggered
and it will do the
first round of reviewing
and we'll generate the PR summary
and also it will generate
first round of the comments
and the comments will have
explanation why it's wrong
and then categorize the two different type
of comment categories.
So, with all that, you know, we found out,
let me show you the number.
So, actually this is a little
bit of live motion here.
So, for a little bit more details
on the Rovo Dev Code Reviewer.
So, it does the automatic code reviewing.
It also suggests a fix for some
of the simple minor comments.
You can directly apply the suggestion.
And there's also a nice thing
is like it looks at the
overall, if you're using Jira.
So, it looks at the
overall acceptance criteria
for this requirement and checks your PR
and give you comments if
it actually doesn't fit
the acceptance criteria.
So, with all this enabled,
what do we see?
With this enabled after
six months we see a 45%
of the PR cycle time reduction.
This is real data.
We did a lot of validation,
just making sure the data was correct.
But we did see really the improvement.
The reason, it's not hard to understand,
the code reviewer agent
does the heavy lifting.
It helps you to summarize the
PR, it gives the first round
of the code review and
point out the common error.
So, common fix.
And then that saves a lot of trouble
for a human reviewer when they come in,
they can look at that, just validate
and they can quickly grasp
what the PR is about.
So, we see an impressive
improvement on the PR cycle time, 45%.
So, this is actually a
good example to validate.
The key here is to understand
the friction point.
Not just to see the symptom
but really understand it, analyze it
and find the right approach to it.
Okay, so
the...
Now, I'm actually recapped.
So, here's the QR code if you wanna scan
and to download the
full report, you can do.
And just to recap, you know
from the report, what we see.
We're seeing AI is
having a positive impact.
It saves four to 20 hours
per week. It's amazing.
It's not surprising with
the rapid AI development,
I'm sure we'll save more,
probably, in the upcoming years,
but significant friction still remains.
People are losing six
to 15 hours per week to inefficiencies,
those inefficiencies
existing in the entire
software development life cycle.
They're everywhere else outside coding.
This is a huge opportunity for us
to look into how AI
tools can actually help
improve the developer experience.
So, pick the right tools for the job.
AI has a positive impact.
Definitely there's a
growing empathy gap there.
So, finding the right tools for the job,
really trying to look at
the application, understand,
analyze your use cases.
Then you will find the right AI tools
for doing the right thing.
I think that's the end
of the presentation.
So, feel free to follow up with me.
I don't think we can take questions here,
but I'll be outside
so if you have any questions
you wanna chat about,
I'll be outside and
also come to our booth.
I think we have a booth
in the Venetian Expo,
so if you wanna come by,
there's more details on how,
within Atlassian, we use AI tools
to help improve the developer experience.
Thanks.
(audience clapping)